cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com I hate to do it to you guys
but we have to do it
we have to do it from the Independent
alien corpses shown to Congress as UFO
expert Force to testify under oath I
thought this was like in Mexico
Jamie uh the guy's name is Jamie
mustsion mausan but what are they this
is this report from the independence
says Congress okay Mexican Congress okay
okay do they have that's what it is it
looks like Yoda
play man yeah what is it look at
the skin like that that's there's no
skin it's a piece it's a chunk of clay
they just yeah
I is so stupid this is this is trending
all day the guys aliens are here Jamie
Mouse and I looked him up it says he's
uh a hoaxer on Wikipedia not the
Wikipedia is legit in any any fashion
but he's known as being a hoaxer but if
I if I look up like ramble Carlson it'll
tell me he's a hoaxer you know so he's
like a legit scientist so I don't know
Jesus Christ and like is this where
we've devolved to where it's like
literally we have some of the most
pivotal times going like an impeachment
inquiry into the actual sitting
president
that and that you know comes after the
other president that was impeached and
now it's being prosecuted and they're
just like look aliens there we go guys
and it's like eventually we're going to
have so many more pivotal moments to the
point where we're gonna run out of stuff
talking about it I think this is were
there any scandals in Mexico today or
yesterday no nothing I know I I'm
wondering if like the Mexican Government
seeing what the Democrats were doing
we're like that's actually a really good
idea yeah in America yeah and
then a scandal-ups and they're like
let's let's just do aliens and so they
get some like little old lady to mold
some like clay figures
what else is that what else I can't
believe that they're actually saying
these are lit these were living
creatures like they literally found like
clay dolls are your best case
interpretation is these were just made
by some dude a thousand years ago who
was like molding clay yeah I mean and
your worst case scenario is they
literally made them the other day to
come for something up I feel like if I
mean if if Mexico was a serious country
and they had these like the first thing
they would be doing is like all right
time to open them up and see what's
inside they're dead but they're not I
mean come on they say X-rays of the
specimen were shown during the hearing
which x with with experts
that one of the bodies has listen listen
under oath they said one of the bodies
has seemed to have eggs inside
how come aliens always have to be like
really small little things like this you
know like because it's not cost less to
make yeah right we didn't want to pay
for the big one they're an Arkansas
State man probably costs a lot already
and now at least now we know why the
aliens lock their doors when they fly by
Earth man those guys are
defenseless like God we uh a Chihuahua
could have marked one of them like well
but you know it's it's like it's it's
sort of when you're driving through a
safari you ever see that there's a video
that came out recently I think it's old
where this man and women are driving and
then the woman and the man get into an
argument so the wind gets out of the car
and then uh lion just grabs the wife and
drags her off and the husband gets out
like oh what do I do it's like dude your
wife's dead I don't know I don't know
dude that gets I know it's
probably scary and it's got it but bro
like if your wife isn't it's surrounded
by lions and she decides to get out of
the car like I'll tell you this is the
lesson that these aliens got to learn
man when you're flying by Earth the
humans may look cute and cuddly but
they're big and they're vicious
department they could have encountered a
flex-sized human and you could have just
been hungry and it could have been
Gardens for uh you know I don't know
what they're going through I don't know
if one of these aliens was about to get
married I don't know
or something they were stopped by Mexico
to get some new sombreros and like it
just went like I don't know man but
let's take Warriors or something it's
nuts so these are apparently fossils
right a thousand-year-old fossils so I
was wondering the same thing why
wouldn't they dig them open but that
means that dude's just like that's crazy
though because we've been scared of
aliens in the Aztecs literally just said
hey hold my bow and arrows and a lot of
man took one out they're not possible
it's clear yeah these people
just like come on you you said something
on one of the the bits today or the
segment today and you were talking about
um about uh neuralink and it made me
think what if like fermi's Paradox is
because
other societies like once you get to the
point where you can be uh where you can
get plugged into like the internet or
whatever like that's what happens to
them like they tend to decide okay I
don't I don't want to go and it fails
what yeah I don't want to go and explore
the universe and stuff because we have
all the ability to go ahead and plug
ourselves in like that was the first
thing I thought I was like I wonder I
wonder if that's a theory that you could
actually test ever one year ago a year
and two months I was making AI images of
Nancy Pelosi and if you look at my
Instagram you'll see how stupid it looks
yeah it's just a weird disfigured face
and I was laughing like look it almost
looks like Pelosi now you can make
realistic photos of Pelosi shaking hands
with Vladimir Putin in 30 seconds 30
seconds is is an exaggeration I'm sorry
it's more like 10. not kidding you go to
you go to Mid Journey you type it in and
bang you gotta go turbo hours I wonder
if I can actually just literally do this
you can't just be fine yeah well it
might say that uh you can't make let's
try Nancy Pelosi shaking hand with Putin
Getty Images it might say you can't make
historical images and I'll have to like
contest it or something okay it worked
uh
they don't they they tell you you're not
allowed to make pictures of trump
getting arrested and things like that
but there's ways to do it like on uh
I I shouldn't say too much because I
like mid-journey I don't want to tell
people how to break their rules but I'll
just give you a basic example like what
if you put woman slips it woman falls on
ground and SP as cover and has red paint
spelled on her
that will be a picture of woman with red
paint on her but it'll look like a woman
who's covered in blood you know what I
mean so like you can still make these
things happen uh it looks like man this
is good this is nuts let me uh
look at this wow
man that's realistic look at the first
one
this is this is crazy now I just I look
at the third one what is this
[Laughter]
so you can hold on let me let me let me
open that one up that's so crazy that's
insane and then yes that's her look and
then that's Putin's signature look like
oh my God this is amazing if Luke's
listening you should make that new
t-shirt man that's sick dude anyway I
mean look how incredible this is a year
ago it was a goofy looking picture of
Nancy Pelosi all scrunched face
we are probably and and so I made a
picture of like a guy in like a
stovepipe hat walking forward with an
explosion behind him and I typed in uh
The Prompt I gave it was something like
final scene from the action movie
steampunk crisis and it made something
like it made that and a bunch of other
things I was like wow I I told it to
make uh final scene of the 80s 80s
superhero movie where Iceman defeats the
evil mayor and it actually made a
widescreen image that looked like an 80s
movie it was nuts
someone took the image I posted on
Twitter and made a three second
animation of the guy and now that three
second animation was about as bad as the
Nancy Pelosi face in one year you will
be able to make a full legitimate like
realistic looking video probably it's
all the only issue is gonna be how long
it takes to render you'll probably be
able to go into mid journey and be like
a 30 second video of Nancy Pelosi doing
a perfect backhand spring or round off
back layout and then it will make that
video and you'll be like damn which
means
we are probably only a few years away
from the cessation of video games movies
books and entertainment music Etc I'm
sorry Phil I don't I don't need you to
record anything for me because I'm going
to be I'm going to say to the AI
um make me a hit song by All That
Remains and it will just take your music
style take the top 40s it will take all
the biggest best metal songs and it will
make a song you singing it in three
seconds and then I'll be like oh hey
here's a song in the style of filibonti
then what happens is I'll say make me a
song
that's make me a heavy metal song top
major hit super entertaining and combine
the voices of the top three heavy metal
lyrics vocalists and then you've got a
totally unique product it's yours you're
gonna be able to do that with video
games we're playing Baldur's Gate not
only matter you're gonna say make me a
video game where it's DND based and the
villain is a giant octopus from outer
space trying to take over the world and
it will render everything because the
basic mechanics of the video games
already exist I wonder if you could just
say make me Baldur's Gate four and yeah
it knows done so we can get the next
Half-Life yes thank God but think about
where this goes you're so man the things
people are not considering the economy
how does the economy exist in a world
like this with automation it's an
investor economy people have talked
about how what are we going to do when
Taco Bell has replaced all its employees
with robots
it's called Robin Hood
you download the app yes and what's
gonna happen is people are going to get
they're going to make money from some
odds and ends here and there because
there'll be tips they'll be busking
there will be social media and then
you're going to start putting those in
different accounts and stocks Taco Bell
still turns a profit you will be a part
owner of Taco Bell and you'll get a
dividend every month for Taco Bell's
profits because you are buying into it
you're staking essentially Taco Bell
coin or something like that all
automated some people will still have to
do work but people will mostly make
money through Investments the rich
people will be those who are smart
enough to predict the future in what
companies will do better and poor people
will be like well you know I get by
here's the crazier thing neurolink does
not have to be surgically implanted no
that what all they need to do
you think about how the AI Works how
these these machines work they Brute
Force they take all the information
available and they start amalgamating it
then they start mapping it and figuring
out what is and what isn't and over a
long enough period of time they figured
it out
they can I I I I do not see why this
would be unreasonable transmit a signal
into your into your brain
and all they have to do is get the brain
scans of every human on earth and then
let an AI figure it out and then what do
they do the AI will figure out a basic
algorithm for writing code to in to to
uh to connect interact with your brain
wirelessly and so
I used to think you wouldn't be able to
do neurolink because everyone's brain is
a unique code we're all snowflakes we
run we run a similar operating system
but it's built from the ground up a
computer is going to be able to Brute
Force through to figure out how to map
your brain and then figure out how the
programming works and it's gonna be able
to do it very very quickly and once they
have enough data on human brain they can
they can create a program that can
simplify basically compress a bunch of
the basic code functions and then write
to your brain when that happens people
won't live in houses anymore and they'll
eat bugs and they'll be happy you know
why because you're not going to go to a
restaurant you're gonna you're gonna
you're gonna go home for whatever reason
you went outside which is going to be
rare you're going to go into your pod
sit down and put your head back and then
the wireless plate touching your neck
will transmit a signal into your brain
and you'll blink and you'll be inside
your mansion
[Music]
with charred uh garlic delicious all you
can eat
people are going to be in the real world
being like you eat bugs but who cares
exactly I don't see bugs I see a creme
brulee cheesecake
I don't I don't see how we get we get
past this these these images that we've
been able to generate are so
nuts in one year's time
how do how does anything other than this
happen it makes me wonder if
people are actually going to be able to
like survive in a totally uh created
world like that now
my gut is they probably will like
I don't imagine that
in the long term they're not going to be
able to decode how your brain works
right so I I think that there might be
problems in the beginning like a lot of
people like the way that they described
it in The Matrix people rejecting it
because there's something that they you
know somehow they know it's not real or
whatever and there's it's not going to
be by force yeah but but listen listen
the the computer
there's there's no rejection the
computer will will will brute force your
brain what I mean what I mean is um I
wonder if people are going to find
meaning because I the the big problem in
society or the big
problem people seem to think that's
going on in society is there's a lack of
meaning so a a secular society does
without religion and stuff people are
are you know I don't have meaning and
that's part of why people think that
there's so many suicides nowadays and I
wonder if in a you know virtual reality
inside your own head kind of thing if
people will accept that and say it's
good enough or if they're still gonna
feel like I don't have meaning because
my children are actually virtual reality
my girlfriend is virtual reality all of
the things that mean something to me
aren't actually real and I wonder if
that will matter or if it's just gonna
fill the need you know what I mean yeah
but you got to think about what hacking
somebody's brain like literally brute
forcing it actually means like we're
nothing but a couple of reactions that
are triggered by electrical signals that
can either come from touching something
physically that runs through Innovations
through our spine and up into our brain
like it's just neurotransmitters and
chemicals being secreted so if they can
mimic the stimuli that creates that
sensation eventually it can override
your sense of memory because you got to
think we're literally computers like
like it's to the point where when you
think about a computer chip
that computer chip before we discover
managerization could only hold so much
data now think about your brain your
brain Can Only Hold so much data
memories and you can only Advance it so
much you you are literally the sum of
your memories and if you can generate
memories through basic Sensations and
basic feedback mechanisms and the AI has
all the Time in the World to do that it
can literally sit around and you know
process combinations process common you
know look at like inputs and different
just virtual simulations of inputs and
what you know what secretion does this
do you know does this um you know does
this affect your serotonin output does
this affect your dopamine like how
dopaminergic is a sensation to this
person what's this person's personality
type like and it can quantify what types
of personalities react to What and just
try it out and try it out and the
algorithm refines itself and you know
it's to the point now it's like they
talk about regulating AI how do you
regulate AI when it grows at a curve
that's exponential you don't even know
what it can do and what it can do
not only that imagine you get the the
neural link doesn't need to be
surgically implanted and so what happens
is you say
I'm gonna go work a job at a gas station
you know because they need or like you
know insert tedious job you attach the
wireless neuralink node to the back of
your neck and then in your mind you're
hanging out playing video games with
your buddies and your body is fixing
tires and like you said if if it doesn't
have to be surgery I bet
everybody does it it doesn't have to be
yeah I I imagine the only if the first
thing we have to do is build the
hardware that can transmit signals to
the brain which I believe we already did
it exists they it's their little EEG
patches right so it's like you know
normally when you stay in a normally
when you have something called epilepsy
you know you've got different types of
seizures you've got apps on seizures
you've got grand mal seizures you've got
the tonic clonics basically and it's
like they have to stick electrodes onto
specific portions of your brain that run
parallel to each other so what they do
is they just stick they use conducting
gel just stick a uh you know a
conducting electrode it's meant to be
more advanced than that they've got
Wireless version yeah they've now got
Wireless versions thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time